i am not interested in being around
grizzly bears you have a fear of grizzly
bears
everyone should have a fear of grizzly
bears because if there was only one
grizzly bear and it was a a myth
like a grizzly bear didn't exist but
then it was in a movie and there was
this thing that's a 900 pound predatory
wild dog that runs it just roams through
the woods no fences yeah yeah no fences
yeah oh you want to climb a tree and get
away
break a moose's bat my friend watched
through a scope he was looking through
like a long range scope yeah he watched
his bear as it was chasing oh [ __ ] he's
chasing him he's chasing him the bear
caught up to the moose and broke its
back with a slap [ __ ] just
bang
and the moose is [ __ ] slams against
the side of this tree the bear took down
a [ __ ] moose
those are just running around and you're
gonna you're gonna have a little cloth
house that you sleep in
but what if you scare them by yelling at
them
well you might scare them off you can
generally speak they're not gonna want
to kill you because you're not a primary
food source right they focus on what
they try to eat they're trying to eat
berries they're trying to eat animals
they're trying to eat a lot of fawns and
calves that's what they want they want
babies right and they get out they're
the most vulnerable and bears are on the
hunt right around that did you see this
one where they oh my god it's the most
terrifying
i've said for years that bears are my
biggest fear and you guys made fun of me
relentlessly wait was it this is the
polar bear this is the polar bear this
one is [ __ ] it's florida yeah there's
mad bears where i live but what's going
on where do you live well i grew up in
florida oh there's a lot of bears in
florida but they were like little black
bears they weren't even that big little
but they'll still kill people but this
thing right here
so this is this is him just being
curious he's just kind of looking no no
no no incorrect you don't you don't
think no that's a polar bear he smells
meat and he's trying to get in there and
eat that dude that's 100 what's going on
he's not curious you know that you're
sniffing around what what he smells like
look at this that polar bear smells that
man's meat that's why he's doing this
this has nothing to do with curiosity he
is trying to bite that box to eat that
man 100 million percent i mean this is
insane yeah because polar bears only eat
meat
they're not like any other bear they're
the most predatory of all bears because
they don't have any other options they
don't have any vegetables there's no
grass all they eat is [ __ ] seals or
anything else yeah photographers
anything that's there
polar bears will come for you so what do
you do in that situation dude pray i
heard the most terrifying story of these
explorers they were on an icebreaker and
they were on an icebreaker i don't even
know if this is true what's the number
tell you
so they're out there in
wherever the polar bears live yeah and
um
they
uh have a leak in their boat they have
to literally get off the boat because
the boat's sinking yeah so they
make their way to an ice raft they get
off the boat onto this ice raft
and they wait and there's multiple hours
before someone can come get them and
they see a polar bear
and they see a polar bear on a
neighboring ice raft yeah and he's
looking at them and he stands up and
bloom comes up in the water and pops up
on the next one next to it oh and
they're like oh man
back in the water pops up on the next
one next to it until he's right next to
them he dives in the water comes up onto
their ice raft takes one of the guys
grabs him pulls him into the water swims
with him over to the other one and
starts eating him [ __ ] right in front of
those dudes
holy [ __ ] so they're standing there
going what
[Laughter]
[ __ ] funny they eat you alive too
they don't bother killing you do they
die from like grizzlies or anything like
that no no i don't i do have friends
that have been chased by grizzlies and
attacked by grizzlies
brown bears well most of the time it's
what they're trying to do is scare you
most of the time it's like a female with
her her cubs and you just zigged when
you shoot a zag
that's his thing he thinks he can zag at
the right moment there's no zagging with
bears
and uh that's happened with friends
where they got charged you know shot at
them
um
what happened with cameron no he never
had to do that but um steve ranella from
that show meat eater has a horrifying
story
if they
shot an elk on a fognac island which is
this island in alaska where the biggest
brown bears live these things are
[ __ ] huge man like 11 foot tall bears
right they're monsters right and they
kill this elk
and when they went back to retrieve it
they noticed bear [ __ ]
and they ignored it and they said let's
just sit down have lunch and we'll carry
this beat out of there and they heard a
noise and then they turned and there was
this
[ __ ] giant beast just running through
the camp and they all stood up and guys
were falling over each other the bear
was like running right past them one guy
this guy's name is dirtmouth wound up on
top of the bear as it was running down
the hill [ __ ] for like 30 feet
falls off onto the ground the bear runs
off into the woods and starts hoofing at
them and they they scramble back to the
camp they didn't have their guns on them
the guns were sitting there all they
were doing was eating lunch they had no
idea it was going to happen this fast
and then all of a sudden then they've
got guns they've got to try to back out
of there
wow but the bear had claimed their elk
of course oh it took their kills
he decided it was theirs oh yeah they
got off easy just lost an elk who cares
who cares they're lucky that i don't
even know if they lost the whole elk i
think they only lost part of it i think
they were in the process of cutting it
up and and shipping it and moving and
moving it back to their camp which was
like a couple of miles away in this
rugged terrain this thing just come out
of nowhere
yeah is it just the bear
do you have to worry about you got to
worry about everything man that's the
the thing that's great about the woods
is that it's a a human reset you you're
when you're like legitimately out in the
mountains it's a human reset right
because you realize like oh oh no one
gives a [ __ ]
no one gives a [ __ ] about you yeah
everything here is trying to do their
thing right the bulls are literally
killing each other the [ __ ] right
they're killing you what do you mean
they grow weapons yeah every year
they compete they kill each other they
attack each
the other will like there'll be
competition whoever wins is the dominant
male that's who the female will mate
with dude
whoever the fight whenever she's in like
a c or whatever yeah that's what male
competition happened she's saying i'm
going to choose the dominant male
because i want the strongest genes for
my offspring yeah i control this because
i got the energy
look they start smashing at the water
those are two big ass bulls and they
decided they both want to be the king
[ __ ] of the herd and so they have to go
to war so if you are in the woods and
you're elk hunting and you hear cloggedy
clack i got crack crack crack crack
crack any clack you're like oh [ __ ]
they're fighting and you could run in
and kill one of those bulls
because they're distracted yeah have you
seen what they got locked up sometimes
they'll like lock up their antlers and
they'll just die that way dude i've
watched this personally from you know 50
yards away really it's amazing it's
amazing to watch
it's wild yes terrifying and then what
happened
well
my situation the wind was bad and we
never really could get a shot it was
like there was too much there was too
many trees and [ __ ] for us by the time
we got to them they had smelled us and
took off what's the biggest animal you
could beat the [ __ ] out of i don't think
i could beat the [ __ ] out of a monkey
no i'm really scared a monkey would [ __ ]
me what about a wolf i'm not kidding
did you see that video do you ever see
that video of a monkey who pulls that
strip of that dude's head off oh monkeys
are freakishly strong but it just climbs
this guy is like trying to be peaceful
he's like on his son is like sitting
crisscross applesauce and the monkey
comes and sits on him it's like hello my
friend he's like and the monkey just
bites his head and pulls a giant chunk
of his scalp off and runs away can you
get that up i mean pulls like a [ __ ]
subway sandwich sized chunk of scalp
from this dude's head i'm not
bullshitting like this big do we have
monkeys uh in america no we do not what
about south america south america has
some monkeys yeah
arien foster he's a football player he
said i could take a wolf yeah he was
crazy we talked about on the podcast
yeah you did a podcast together that's
ridiculous no chance no impossible even
you you're no no no no no no chance no
chance no chance you would get it's
literally like a machine that crushes
moose bones okay
okay
so no animals a wolf's bite is five
times stronger than a pit bulls okay did
you see this and their teeth are
designed to crush both oh this is the
craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen what are
you doing in this situation so this is a
this is a family that went to thailand
for like a trip okay if i'm not mistaken
so they're like hanging out and they go
to like an orangutan exhibit and this is
like one of this is not graphic but this
is one of the things that they do
but she's just chilling there and then
yeah they do like an orangutan
experience and this is what happens he
walks up behind her mm-hmm
she starts grabbing grabbing her boobs
smiling tongue out he smiles and then
just dips
but i don't think i would want to be
that close an orangutan ever in my life
no yeah it's unnecessary if that thing
wanted to it could pull you apart like a
roll of toilet paper just shh
yeah you could pull you apart like you
were nothing yeah these people like we
we think of our like oh it's not that
much bigger than me it's like uh it's
kind of the same size as me it's not
even the same thing yeah strength to
weight ratio we're made out of jelly
[Laughter]
that's what it is there's not a goddamn
animal where you wouldn't be able to
fight off a feral cat
bears are the scariest animal i'm glad
we actually cleared that up i think
they're one of the scariest i accept
that as an apology but big cats might be
even scared i'm more afraid of a big cat
yeah big cats are scared way more afraid
about bears i feel like i could get away
or if i feel like i could do something
but with a tiger i'm being dead serious
well the tiger a lion i feel like
there's nothing do you remember when you
scared me with the bear thing no
do you remember this i forget where we
were we're at some comedy club i told
you about fear of bears and i was like
on edge all day because i was like going
through all my childhood trauma of bears
and then you just popped out of nowhere
at the comedy club i think we're in like
salt lake city do you have a lot of
childhood trauma with bears i mean kind
of as a kid it was the scariest thing in
the world because we would just be
sitting in our house and all of a sudden
all the trash cans would rattle and i'm
like six years old and all the dogs
would start barking crazy and then we'd
run outside there'd be a bear there and
florida bears are like florida people
yeah they're all very very unpredictable
smoking pcp these babies are crazy
unpredictable running from the law
wearing trump hats
and [ __ ] bro these bears have guns dude
and i would go outside i would just bump
into one and i'd run inside i'm like six
years old and then my family found out
about it they bought a bear mask and
then we had a full bear mask and i'd be
sleeping in my bed eight years old my
brother kicks in the door wakes me up
and growling and i'd wake up and there'd
be a bear
this is amazing so we made fun of you
because of this yeah i didn't listen to
a lot of things you said earlier
and then they knew once i got
comfortable with the bear mask then they
just flipped the mask inside out oh my
god it was like just a beige oh and then
we did something did we bring it out of
the kitchen planning to do it
i don't know if we ever did it
real bears are [ __ ] they're weird to
see because you
actually see them in the wild like
i saw one grizzly and it wasn't a big
one it was only about six feet tall but
it stood up and it was looking at us it
was looking at us in a totally different
way than anything's ever looked at me i
saw a bear when i was in [ __ ] montana
and it's cub
nothing to me it didn't i was biking
bear might have been a black bear maybe
a black beard grizzly bear
i swear to god in my life i was at my
boy at mundo's my bachelor party we're
doing a bike trip i don't believe you
you need to get i have a
he's not thing with you he's fighting
against the feeling the weed is bringing
inside of you what is the feeling i
don't think i'm high anymore i think it
passed oh yeah you're fine okay let's
get him a little bit more than more
afraid of babies give us give us a blunt
because we're in new york where you are
we gotta smoke a backwood oh yeah pop
these out on the ground bring them bring
the whole joint over here on the ground
no i give the whole thing oh we got the
dipped ones that's too crazy for me but
just bring out the whole thing over and
then we can choose so here's my answer
on the ground a bear is not as scary as
a shark is in the water oh bro shark is
the apex
way more afraid of sharks way more
afraid of uh alligators
way more afraid of
have you ever smoked a backwood joe yeah
you really have yeah who the [ __ ] you
smoke about i'm telling you it's not
that unique to new york
no i thought this is like a brooklyn new
york thing no they spread around charlie
murphy introduced me to okay that makes
a little more sense the concept back in
the day he was the first guy i ever
smoked blunts with and i was like oh
really i was like this is better
yeah blunts are better